He served in World War One and World War Two.
He's still one of Germany's most respected military leaders and yet he never
even wanted to be in the military.
Who is this man that led the German troops to victories but defined Hitler at
his own peril?
What made him who he is and what keeps his name and the history books?
Well,
that's what we're looking at in today's biographics,
the life of Erwin Rommel,
the Desert Fox
hold in Germany in 1891 oh when Rommel half have the military in his DNA.
His father was a teacher and he was the only member of his family to enter the
military as a career.
Obvious three siblings that live to adulthood.
At one brother,
it became a dentist and other became an opera singer and his sister became an
art teacher as a child role,
wasn't particularly athletic.
In fact,
he's even been described as frail,
but he hit his stride and his early teens discovering sports and becoming a
leader among his peers.
Around this same time,
he also discovered his love of mathematics and engineering.
He built his own glider and was known to spend his free time taking apart
machinery and putting it back together again,
a teenage rumble,
even dismantles and entire motorcycle and rebuilt this now Robel he was clearly
intelligent,
but his grades,
they didn't reflect it without good grades.
Rommel couldn't continue his education at university with his talent for
machinery.
He considered working at a factory near his childhood home,
but his father didn't want him working that.
Instead,
his father pushed grumble into military service.
At the age of 18 Rommel began studying it.
The officer Cadet School in Tokyo was part of the 124 for Wurtenburg infantry
regiments.
He graduated in 1911 and by January of 1912 was commissioned as second
lieutenants as a battery commander.
He became part of the 124 for Weingarten regiments.
He showed his military talent early on.
He was still a young men and it's no surprise the rumble has more going on in
his life than just his military service.
Rommel had met a young woman by the name of Walburga stenner while he was posted
in wine.
Gotten the two began and romance and wild bagger rented up pregnant when rubble
the ends of her pregnancy.
You promised that they would marry and live in a house and be a family before
they could marry.
Very wild dog gave birth to her daughter that she named to Gertrude.
Months later,
Rommel stationed away from Weingarten sent well bag or a letter the contained
far different news than what she expected.
The lesser broke the news that he couldn't marry her.
She wasn't from the right class to be an officer's wife and was Korea was his
priority.
Then there was the fact that he was also in love with another woman.
The other woman was at Lucy Mollin.
She and Matt,
while he was in cadet school,
though they did not marry until 1916 rumbles a clear commitment to Lucy did not
stop Walberg out from loving him,
though she stayed devoted to him for years,
believing that as long as he never had children with another woman,
that was a chance that he would return to her,
but he never did.
In 1928 Walburga lands that Lucy was pregnant with Rommel's trials,
unable to deal with the news.
She killed herself.
Rommel and Lucy were supportive of Gertrude both financially and emotionally.
They welcome time into their home.
They did introduce her as their niece when Lawler was fighting in Africa.
The scarf that he wore was knitted for him by Gertrude Rommel and Lucy's own
son,
man.
Fred was born in 1928 and even went on to become mayor of Stuttgart for 20
years.
That's almost family life was taking shape,
so was his military career months after his illegitimate daughter was born in
world war one,
broke out role,
began his war service as a platoon commander in Verdun where he soon established
the fearlessness that he became known for only a month into the war.
He'd charge degree for French soldiers with a banner ads on his own.
He had no ammunition but the French troops did rumble.
It was shot in the leg,
but this was only to be the first of many injuries that he sustained during his
military service.
Rommel was so well known for charging.
It had an ending up in the thick of this,
this his trips used to see where Rommel is there as the front [inaudible] served
in France,
Romania,
and SLE during World War One.
He was not only respected for his courage,
for his leadership and implementing new strategies and maneuvers for warfare.
One of rumbles,
most exceptional victories came as he led troops in the mountainous region of
Kappa rata in Italy.
Rommel streets where polyphasic conditions were horrific,
but with the use of new infiltration tactics.
The German Nan Austro-hungarian troops had a decisive victory over the Italian
army.
9,000 Italian men were captured 150 of them offices,
Rommel.
It didn't achieve this by following orders.
It's quite the contrary.
In fact,
when he was told to stand down,
he moved forward and attacked.
He also used a strategy you have coming out the attacks from surprising
directions and creating confusion and disorder among the Italian trips for his
role in the battle,
Rommel received the Paul and Mary.
It's a prestigious German Order of merit.
Even before his achievements of the Battle of Cup Hereso Rommel has earns the
iron cross and had been promoted to first lieutenant.
In 1918 he received another promotion to captain when World War One ended.
Rommel stayed in the military,
leaving the 30th infantry regiment and still got most of the work involved
dealing with civil unrest,
but Rommel didn't use the same aggressive tactics he was known for in the
battlefields.
In fact,
the avoided using force as much as he could and negotiations took the place of
action in the town of Lindau rather than attack the communists,
he was staging an uprising and the town rumble used to diplomacy to get the
cities governments back under control recognized for his leadership
capabilities.
Rommel was sooner pointed to two teeth Shanthi Dresden infantry school.
Among the advice a Lawford future military leaders is this advice that he
followed in his own military career.
Be an example to your men and your duty hand in your private life.
Never spare yourself and let the troops see that you don't in your endurance and
fatigue and privation.
Always be tactful and well mannered and teach your subordinates to do the same.
Avoid excessive sharpness or harshness of voice,
which usually indicates the man who has shortcomings of his own to hide during
this time at Rommel also said to work putting his military strategies on paper.
In 1934 Rommel Oseberg on infantry training was published.
He was no longer teaching having left that role in 1933 but he was leading
troops in gossip.
It was in Gossler that he encountered at off it and for the first time Hitler
was chancellor and he was in Gosselaar to inspect troops.
By 1937 Hitler was well aware of Ronald Man,
his reputation.
He names Rommel,
the war ministry liaison for the Hitler youth,
but Rommel was not a member of the Nazi party.
He ends another hit.
The youth leader disagreed about tactics and organization for the group and in
the end,
rumble lost his role in 1938 even though Rommel wasn't a member of the Nazi
party,
he was still a supporter of Hitler during his rise to power.
He did agree with Hitler's efforts to re militarize and do unify Germany and
Hitler still wanted Rommel in the upper echelons of the military.
In fact,
he made a direct request that rubble will be part of the units that traveled
with Hitler.
The assignment not only gave Rommel access to the fear,
but it also gave him more free time for his hobbies and interests than he had
ever had before.
He wants again,
started focusing on math and engineering and even took time away to go skiing,
but this wasn't a loss because war,
it was just around the corner.
1939 was a watershed year for Europe and it's the wells under Hitler's orders.
Germany invaded Poland on September the first 1939 as part of the preparation
for the invasion,
Rommel had been promoted to major general and was entrusted with protecting
Hitler as war erupts says.
Then in 1940 Ronald was put in charge of the seventh Panzer Division,
the Panzer divisions made up of armored tanks.
Well,
an ideal opportunity for rumble to put his particular strategic skill set on
display.
Initially plans were for rum olds who heads up a mountain division first.
With the support Rommel was able to land at the head of the division.
He wants it in addition to armored tanks.
Rommel was also leading rifle regiments,
a motorcycle battalion as an engineer.
The Talia,
Andy was doing this out of the usual order of military protocol when Hitler made
Romola General.
He bypassed other more experienced military men to do so.
This started some grumblings within the German military,
but Rommel assume proved himself to be worthy off the rank.
He puts his division through their training pieces for months and in May they
sat off for battle and France.
The battle,
it didn't start out well for ramen and an air strips.
Bridges were out where they needed to cross a river and it's the French were
firing,
stopping the German troops from making attempts to cross,
but Rommel outsmarted them.
He's our building's on fire creating a wall of smoke that gave it strips the
cover they needed as they fired her back across the river at the French.
They then got in rubber boots and made their way across the water using
materials from another panzer division.
They built a bridge and the full division moved across Rommel.
He wasn't standing back and giving orders.
No.
The general was actually in the thick of the action firing a machine gun and
even wading into the water to put the bridge together.
Once again,
Ramos Division made quick progress.
Within days they captured 10,000 French soldiers and only lost three doesn't
have their own men.
For this victory,
Rommel was awarded the Knight's cross.
In the coming weeks.
Rommel continues has advanced across France.
He announced success is to had learned a telegram containing only four words.
I'm on the coast.
Throughout the seventh panzer divisions move across France.
Rumble moved his trips so quickly in surreptitiously that even the German high
command couldn't keep track of them.
This led them to debates the ghost division off to the gentleman's march through
France,
the stories a Roosevelt,
Rommel shooting,
an unarmed French prison off and not following orders.
He's also been accused of involvement in the massacre of French African soldiers
from Senegal and men under his command were involved in the killing of dozens of
men who are surrendering and therefore posed no threat to the German soldiers.
While some of his troops were very likely involved in such a trustee's,
historians believe rumble would not have given commands for such brutal attacks.
According to historian Rafael Shack,
although there is no evidence incriminating,
Rama themself is unit did find in areas where German massacres of black French
prisoners of war were extremely common.
In June,
1940 after the gym Taiko for France,
the plan it was at first for Ronald's to had to Britain.
That would be the next nation the Germany would take over.
But it was decided that the German air force wasn't strong enough to do what
needed to be done in order to take over England's and instead Rommel was sent to
Africa.
The Afrika Korps was a newly created division of the German military and General
Rummel was the man who led it to victories.
The Italians had been suffering crushing losses in northern Africa and Hitler
wanted the Germans there to beat back.
The British royal arrived in the in 1941 and he was supposed to answer to the
Italian commanding military officer,
but he disagreed with the Italians tactics.
They wanted the Italian and German troops to use a defensive strategy.
Rommel wanted to advance and take on with the British directly.
Hedler agreed with Rommel man's Rommel began planning an offensive.
The British,
however,
had no idea that was the plan.
The only intelligence was the rumbles orders,
where to stay put.
When Romo moved districts forward,
they were caught a well off guard,
rumbles slimer nuvaring.
It's proved fruitful for him once again,
but even with success,
the Italian lead a Garibaldi was not happy.
Rommel,
her disobeyed orders and then matter the outcome.
That was not the way the military was supposed to work.
However,
Rommel,
he had a response for Garibaldi value.
One can often,
they're two unique opportunities to sit by for the sake of trifles outside of
Germany.
Rummel was capturing the attention of world leaders.
Winston Churchill was 90 water.
What else matters?
But beating him,
but the nickname he owns it.
His clandestine maneuverings in Africa is what a stuck through the decades of
history,
and I would be the Desert Fox,
but its successes.
They came to an ends.
The British recaptured,
the city of Tobruk and rumbles games had been lost.
Then rumble was part of a crucial meeting with Hitler Ins and other German
military leader elders,
Castle ring,
the two field marshals.
They disagreed and how the Germans should move forward.
Initially they presented their arguments and Hitler agreed with castle ring.
Gasser ring took over and Rommel was moved to do need the troops on the coast of
France.
By the time Romo was reassigned to France,
he was starting to be more and more skeptical of Hitler.
His strategies and his goals are almost,
didn't support the brutal actions,
the SS,
and eventually you came to believe that Germany would be better off negotiating
an end to the war instead of continuing the carnage and all the death,
and he wasn't alone in his beliefs.
A group of men who agreed with Rommel,
even suggested that he should become Geminis new leader.
Though Rommel didn't act on that suggestion,
the mere fact of the suggestion ultimately helped seal rumbles face from the
time he was in charge of coastal forces.
In 1943 Rommel spent his time and strategy building up coastal defenses.
He says mine's built barbed wire obstructions and even had troops flood areas of
the coast to make it harder for trips to pass.
Three he also wanted to bring more tanks closer to the coast,
better.
No one else agreed with them that that was necessary.
In the summer of 1944 it would turn out to there's Rommel,
well,
he was riced wants to move more tanks to the coast.
On June the fifth 1944 Rummel left France.
He headed home to Germany so that he could be with his wife on her birthday.
June the sixth when he left France,
he and the rest of the German military thought the weather would be bad and they
didn't have to worry about any allied movements on the coast and they also
thought that if any trouble was to come,
it would be a Kelly,
but the allies had used the German military is weak intelligence system to get
them to think that the attack would come at Cali.
While he was a time celebrating his wife's birthday,
Rommel received a phone call that shocked him.
The allies had landed at Normandy on June the SEC.
The weather had cleared and the trips were storming.
The beaches rumbled left Germany immediately to hand to the front.
He and other leaders establish to counter attack plan,
but I live fire was too strong and needed troops when table to arrive.
Rommel himself was injured badly by allied air strikes and the ends 155,000
allied troops landed during the d day invasion growing to 1 million after the
initial push,
the fourth stormed through German defenses during the summer of 1944 it's a
rumble.
It was clear that jam and he couldn't overcome the losses and so you continued
forward march of the allies.
He broke the news of his assessment to hit not telling him the tape political
solution was likely the best way forward.
At this point,
the fear,
though he did not agree this meeting would ultimately be the lost between the
two men as victory for Germany was looking less and less likely,
opposition to Hitler was growing in Germany.
High ranking military officials,
including those close to Rommel where it's starting to make plans to get rid of
the Fiera assassination was among the many options they contemplated.
Knowing Rommel disagreed with Hitler.
Runs was growing increasingly upset with the fear of the men plotting to
overthrow.
Hitler tried to bring him into the fault.
To this day,
it's unclear ref.
Rommel was actually involved in a plot to assassinate Hitler on us,
and if he was,
it's unclear just how much he knew.
His widow later said,
Rommel only wanted Hitler to be brought to court and it's nothing more.
If you're a though he fought to,
there's a rumble,
wanted him dead and in the end that's what matters.
I'm July 20th,
1944 a group of conspirators smuggled a bomb inside the briefcase into a meeting
at Hitler's headquarters that was supposed to be two bombs,
but there was only time to prepare one and two when it exploded.
The survived instead of a successful key with the conspirators found themselves
facing treason charges and the death penalty and Rommel was among those
indicators.
In October,
1944 two or fitness generals confronted rumble as ss troops surrounded the area.
The generals told Rommel that he had three options and you could go to speak to
Hitler directly and explain himself and he could go to court or he could commit
suicide there.
And then Rommel,
Molly opted for suicide in his final communication with his wife.
He explains why in view of my services in Africa,
I have the chance of dying by poison.
Two generals have brought it with them.
It is fatal in three seconds.
If I take the poison,
none of the usual steps will be taken against my family.
That is against you.
They will also leave my staff alone.
Having explained to his family what was to happen,
Ron more got into an ss car.
He took the Sinai Capsi,
all that Hitler's general had brought and he died.
He was wearing his Africa corps jacket and carrying his field marshal's baton.
The world was told he died of wounds he had sustained from allied air attacks in
the wake of d day,
and he was buried with full military honors only after the war did the truth
emerge.
Rommel was not maps with the same disdain from world leaders.
There's other Germans were in the wake of World War II.
Even Winston Churchill spoke highly of him.
He also deserves our respect because although a loyal German soldier,
he came to hate him and all his works and took part in the conspiracy to rescue
Germany by displacing the maniac and tyrants for this,
you paid the forfeit of his life,
uh,
when Rommel was a talented leader,
but his military duty survey regime that had terrible intentions and committed
horrific atrocities were almost life and death were intertwines with a watershed
era in human history.
An era upon which he left his mark.
So really have you found that video?
Interesting?
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe.
We put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday.
Also check out some videos from the archive over there on the right.
Also,
if you want to vote on who we do on this channel,
please head over to our website and do say there is a link in the description
below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.